a very good morning to you thanks so
much for talking to us Jonathan Reynolds
let's start with the issue of Asylum
because the focus this week has very
much been on Asylum Seekers It's been
the issue of the week hasn't it what
would labor do what specifically would
you do to reduce the number of people
who are coming here by unsafe means
good morning yes and certainly has been
the the story of the week I mean the
entire approach from government to me
lacks any sense of basic competence or
compassion look there's no easy way to
address a crisis like this but
fundamentally what we would do is
process that backlog of claims I think
we have the worst
um of all Worlds at the minute where
people who who should be qualifying for
refuge in this country have to wait too
long for it in conditions which are
unacceptable and people who shouldn't be
in this country aren't processed quickly
enough and then told to leave the
country and crucially rather than have
gimmicks expensive gimmicks like the
Rwanda plan which clearly hasn't
deterred anyone from trying to come to
the UK we would spend that money on the
National Crime Agency on a specific sale
designed to stop those people smuggling
who are clearly involved in this trade
but that's the only way to tackle this
is competence tackling the claims that
come in in the way which frankly the
country did in the past and no longer
does and focusing our policing and Law
and Order resources on the criminal
gangs who are involved in it what about
opening up new kinds of routes into the
country that are safer that perhaps
could deter people from taking uh trips
in small boats across the channel open
up more safer legal routes
well I think you obviously must have
safer and legal routes to come to the UK
and particularly when they respond to
particular conflicts around the world
that have led to Refugee flaws coming
through that but I'll be frank I don't
think any of that would address the
problem if we have over a hundred
thousand uh people currently waiting for
their for their claims to be processed
as is the case today I mean that's up
from 40 000 five years ago I understand
just four percent of the claims relating
to people who came to the country last
year have been processed I mean how can
a system operate in that kind of
environment and I just don't feel the
government is interested in addressing
their own clearly basic failures in this
area and that's why you have this
never-ending set of gimmicks of frankly
things which won't make a difference
because they're trying to deflect from
the fact they've been unfortunately
completely incompetent on this
you talk about people being held in
unacceptable conditions uh talking to
the policing Minister earlier he said
that a number of people have been moved
out of Manson for example and into
hotels do you have Asylum seekers in
your constituency in hotels there
yes I mean people will be aware an area
like mine I represent a tame slider on
the east side of Manchester the how the
system works isn't it actually areas
um of the country where accommodation is
cheaper tend by this government to take
the burden of that now I've checked the
figures for my local area this week it's
actually less than I thought it would be
but this is a reality for people and
fundamentally comes down to the fact
that the government doesn't address the
basic cause of this in the way that it
should and that's that's the frustration
that people have with how the system
works so you you said that you've got
the figures of the people in in your
constituency are you happy to have more
migrants move to your constituency or
your constituents happy about having
people there and moved away from Kent
and away from processing centers like
manston well people around this country
and my constituents are no different to
understand the national nature of this
problem and are willing to play their
part in it I will be frank there is a
times resentment uh the fact that some
parts of the country are asked to take a
bigger share of the burden of this and
the government tends not to fund that in
the way that I think is required but the
cause of this what people want they want
the country to be a Bastion of
compassion to people who are genuinely
seeking refuge and need to be in this
country for that reason and they're very
happy to support that and actually local
organizations local Civic Society
particularly churches and Faith
communities play a massive role within
that but what they expect from
government is some competence is that
they're going to process these claims
they're going to make sure people are
you know given the compassion they
deserve or if they're not eligible to be
in the country process accordingly and
then leave the country and that is what
we haven't got at the minute and if it's
getting worse year on year the longer
the conservatives in power the worse
this problem gets well yes and and Kent
County councilors are have put forward
complaints about saying that that county
is taking an unnecessary uh level of
burden in terms of dealing with with
extra people would you say you were
happy to offer up your hotels and your
constituency as places that they should
travel to
look because this is like mine probably
doesn't have a significant number of of
hotels so it's it's not a practical
offer or or ability to to do it in that
way I can understand how local
representatives in in a place like
Kentfield they have to take a
considerable burden of this the
geography of the country is part of that
but again what they need is an approach
from government which is competent which
is compassionate which addresses the
root cause of this which isn't about
gimmicks or grandstanding or home
secretaries who frankly shouldn't be
restored to government trying to
grandstand for their own political
Ambitions you know this country will in
many countries in Europe have had this
this situation this issue to deal with
for some time but it hasn't in the last
few years in particular been dealt with
in the way it should be done and that is
at the cause of resentment I think the
government had some basic competence on
this you wouldn't see the resentments
and the pressures which we currently see
all around the country
I want to turn attention to to the
economy now if I can reports out this
morning that size well C the nuclear
plant for Suffolk that's been that's
being planned is now under review as the
government tries to cut spending Chris
Phil can confirm whether or not that was
true these are these are reports at this
stage but what do you make of that
we support a new nuclear power station
that site what really frustrates me at
the minute is I think you're seeing the
government flying kites every day some
expectation management around the Autumn
statement the reality is they've crushed
the economy and they've got to then take
corrective action because of it but what
would really frustrate me is to see Cuts
in the kind of Investments which
actually are crucial to the long-term
prosperity of the country I mean the one
thing I'll say Liz trust was right on
was that it's not just the last month
it's been a problem for the British
economy it's the last 12 years I mean
the economy hasn't grown as it should
have done and what you see with the
government flying these kites every day
in the media before they give us some
firm information is something which
further undermines confidence in the UK
I mean despite all the brilliant things
we have going for us in this country
that the UK is the country with the
lowest level of business investment in
the G7 and political instability leading
to economic instability has been a major
cause of that and for me the
conservatives will never be the answer
to that because Unfortunately they are
directly responsible for it size wall
for example has a has a 20 billion pound
price tag roughly labor obviously would
be Keen to back that still going ahead
um also making commitments on on tax for
example saying that you're committed to
the triple log are you in a position now
where you're committing to to higher
spending at a time when the chancellor
suddenly says that we can't afford it
well first of all we're going to make a
distinction between long-term investment
spending in the UK and day-to-day
Revenue spending now for us on
day-to-day spending we would not spend a
penny more than we raise in taxation we
don't believe in the conservative
approach that you can borrow money to
pay for unfunded tax cuts for the well
often include one of the reasons we're
in such a situation is where they've got
to so where we would for instance have
an expanded NHS Workforce improve the
backlogs in the NHS that money would
come from abolishing the non-dom rule of
bringing about 3.2 billion pounds we
would tax the income from private Equity
uh money differently we would not have
charitable status for private schools so
every time we we present a spending
commitment on day-to-day spending we'll
always say where that money came from
and that's why we can put them forward
those policies but particularly on
borrowing money you can borrow money to
address a crisis you can borrow money to
invest in the long term investments the
country needs but you can't borrow money
for day-to-day spending